c'est un peu dur mais comme on m'a donné
rendez vous ici aujourd'hui avec vous et
que je m'attendais pas à ce qu'il y ait
autant de monde
je peux vous dire que de toute façon
c'est pas trop grave parce que dans le
fond
j'adore les surprises et en plus j'adore
faire des nouvelles rencontres
mais ce que j'aime par dessus tout c'est
me lancer des défis avec tedx je suis
servi et peut-être que demain je vais
pas en lancer avec vous vous posez
peut-être cette question qu'est ce que
je fais dans ma vie ou plutôt qu'est-ce
que je vais faire dans ma vie
alors j'aime mettre de la couleur là où
il n'y en a pas j'aime impulser des
idées et tenter de les partager avec un
maximum de personnes j'aime investir des
lieux qui sont prêts à tomber et les
animer une dernière fois pour que
surtout on ne les oublie pas mais tout
ça en fait pourquoi pourquoi tout ça et
puis surtout comment comment réaliser
tout ça alors tout a commencé avec la
maladie ma maladie
la chance de ma vie
le diagnostic est tombé polyarthrite
chronique évolutive foudroyante
je ne pouvais plus marcher je ne pouvais
plus avancer
mais j'étais vivante vivante
or paris et je suis arrivé en bretagne
au centre de rééducation fonctionnelle
de kerpape
vous imaginez le choc de ma vie super
active à paris j'ai passé en 33 tours
vivait au ralenti
et puis je me suis mise à réaliser
combien quand je travaillais à paris
dans la pub
combien je me la pète est un peu combien
je pensais qu'à moi et quand je suis
tombé malade je me suis retrouvé face à
des nouvelles réalités et là je crois
que je devais la composent et un peu
autrement cette vie et j'avais plus de
choix alors soit je sombrais je
continuais de malades eux de me lamenter
d'être pas très sympa avec tout mon
entourage et je continuerai et les
autres continuerait à avoir pitié de moi
soit je me mettais à courre à courir
plus vite qu'elle très très vite et ça
m'a fait très mal
j'ai couru longtemps et quand je me suis
arrêté
elle n'était plus là
je me suis dit qu'est ce que je vais
faire maintenant qu'est ce que je vais
faire maintenant parce qu'en fait quand
on est malade c'est une parenthèse qui
s'ouvre et on a le temps on a le temps
de voir passer la vie des autres
derrière les carreaux et on a le temps
aussi de réfléchir à sa vie mais j'étais
en bretagne et je continuerai d'être
heureuse ici et puis j'ai rencontré
hubert hubert photographe et suis tombée
amoureuse
j'ai eu deux fils et malgré tout je
continuer d'être à côté à côté de la vie
active
cette vie active et en 2002 alors que
j'accompagnais hubert sur des reportages
à lorient j'ai eu le déclic
le déclic on devait faire des portraits
d'habitants qui vivait le grand
renouvellement urbain dans le quartier
de kervénanec et je peux vous assurer
que c'est pas simple de rentrer dans la
vie des gens de rentrer dans leur
intimité
en fait il fallait un petit peu
dédramatiser leur expliquer que c'était
aussi pour améliorer leur habitat pour
changer leur environnement et on n'y
arrivait pas on était perdus ils
disaient qu'ils allaient perdre leur
voisin qu'ils allaient perdre leur vie
que eux ils allaient perdre leur
appartement qu'ils allaient tout perdre
qu'il n'avait pas choisi déjà de vivre
ici dans ce quartier et que là ils
n'avaient pas choisi ce départ ce
nouveau départ alors ça me faisait mal
je me suis mis à leur place et je me
suis dit si demain si demain moi aussi
on disait on va détruire la maison
en fait il y avait tellement
d'incompréhension de tristesse de colère
et récupère on n'y pouvait rien on était
là on était juste venue faire un
reportage faire des photos alors on
s'est dit que peut-être on pouvait déjà
faire ça leur offrir une photo un
portrait de famille qui leur laisserait
se souvenir de leur ancienne vie de leur
passage dans cet appartement dans ce
lieu ayant plus on était sûr que quelque
part il afficherait bientôt dans leur
nouvel appartement
c'était tellement heureux de remporter
ça dans leur vie que ça se voyait sur
les photos il rayonnait mais après quand
on rentrait chez nous moi j'avais
toujours cette phrase qui frappait dans
la tête nous met à la porte dans le fond
ils nous mettent à la porte
met à la porte
je me suis dit c'est pas possible il
faut absolument qu'on écrive une
histoire une belle histoire pour qu'on
se souvienne de ces gens pour qu'on ne
les oublie pas mais surtout pour qu'on
les aide à passer ce cap là d'une façon
positive et là je me suis dit je vais
créer l'art s'emporte l'art s'emporte
une histoire de porte c'est tout un
symbole une porte c'est un passage vers
l'autre alors j'ai imaginé cette
histoire et je me suis dit il faudrait
qu'on récupère des portes dans un
quartier dans un immeuble qui serait
bientôt détruit et qu'on pourrait
peut-être les proposer à qui voudrait
dans la ville qui prennent la porte aux
6e et qu' il puisse en faire une
véritable oeuvre
mais cette porte c'est pas n'importe
quelle porte qu'on allait leur donner
c'était une porte ces familles avec un
passé une porte qui avaient été ouvertes
fermées claqué et là ils ont ils
allaient faire une oeuvre d'art de cette
porte si on était sûr c'est en 2005
c'est en 2005 que la ville de lanester
accepte le projet laventure démarre
enfin
fin octobre mais en même temps à paris
les banlieues brûle et se révoltent et
là dans un journal je lis un matin en
gros titre et toi qu'est ce que tu cram
demain et là je me dis mais c'est pas
possible
mais on peut pas écrire des choses comme
ça on peut pas on peut peut-être aussi
passer à des belles histoires racontées
des belles histoires qui se passent dans
ces quartiers là dans ces quartiers
sensibles
j'étais vraiment très en colère
je lui ai dit aux journalistes aussi
demain nous allons vivre une très belle
histoire à lanester alors venez bingo
quinze jours après le journaliste
écrivait l'histoire de l'art s'emporte
et là toutes les télés ont suivi et les
magazines nationaux aussi c'était la
première d'une grande aventure humaine
et urbaines avec d en porter et cette
aventure on a pu la vivre avec des gens
comme vous comme moi toute la ville a
joué le jeu les voisins les familles des
étudiants des artistes n'est pas artiste
des malades des solitaires des retraités
ils ont tous choisi leurs portes
leurs portes avec ses traces du passé
c'était très fort il n'oubliait pas du
coup toutes ces familles qui venaient de
perdre leur logement
ça a duré sept mois
sept mois faites moi pour créer comme
des fous
sept mois ne penser qu'à sa porte sept
mois avec des rendez vous pour partager
le futur stress de la grande exposition
et ce jour de la grande exposition à
midi ils étaient tous là endimanchés
tellement beau tellement fiers ils
étaient tous là posé près de leur porte
raconté leurs créations et par où il
était passé mais moi je me rappelle
surtout deux jeunes hommes jeune homme
qui n'avait plus aucun lien avec sa
famille parce qu'il ne voulait pas les
décevoir et surtout parce qu'il avait
choisi de vivre sa vie autrement
et là il a invité sa famille et ils ont
posé avec lui près de sa porte
près de son oeuvre où il représentait
tout son univers et c'est vrai qu'on ne
retrouvait souvent sur ses portes un peu
de leur quotidien
beaucoup de leur passion mais aussi une
certaine délivrance
j'ai pas eu grand chose à faire pour que
ça marche ça s'étripe côté tout seul à
la confiance au partage et aux belles
rencontres
on a eu cinq mille visiteurs à
l'exposition des s'emporte s'emporte
cents oeuvres créées avec le coeur ceux
qui ont perdu leur logement n'était plus
du tout les mêmes à l'arrivée et en plus
on a raconté leur histoire dans toute la
france leur vie l'histoire de leur
quartier
alors ils étaient fiers et cette
histoire elle a été copié dans plus de
dix villes en france et je crois que ça
c'est le plus beau de tous les
compliments j'ai moi aussi refermer la
porte de cette super belle aventure et
ça tombait plutôt bien puisque à lorient
il y avait un nouveau grand
renouvellement urbain et là ça voulait
dire que un nouveau projet de laisser
idées détournées idées détournées me
démener détour idées détournées des
tournées dans le monde entier idées
détournées pour tous des tournées pour
inventer des lieux de liberté les cours
de récréation pour tous mais cette fois
c'est avec une belle bande de
détourneurs motivés que nous avons tout
recommencer
on avait envie d'aller plus loin on
avait envie d'aller plus haut alors on a
proposé à la ville de lanester la
création d'un musée éphémère
vous imaginez un musée à kervénanec dans
un quartier sensible
et là ça serait un lieu où chaque
habitant créateur pourrait s'exprimer en
3d une espèce de grosse colo création
sur deux états dans dix appartements au
premier et au deuxième de cette tour là
les élus ont été conquis on a lancé le
défi des gens de toutes horizons ont
investi les pièces une véritable ruche
de 380 kokolo créateurs tout le monde
s'entraîne chacun ose les habitants de
la tour expose aussi leur mal être
c'est un vrai chantier un mixage de
population comme on ne pouvait pas
l'imaginer et les djeuns du quartier
d'habitat dans la cage d'escalier ont
aussi partagé ce projet il découpait
tous les articles de la presse mais
surtout ils étaient devenus les gardiens
du musée
mois plus tard le résultat est plus que
surprenant déroutant on y découvre des
réalisations complètement folle à en
perdre la tête
on sait plus trop bien où on en est et
on en perd toute notion de réalité les
enfants l'appellent le château les
visiteurs parcourent chacune des 60 de
pièces comme de véritables cabinet de
curiosités ils sont tous transportés et
qui reviennent tous aussi avec leurs
amis leurs familles pour les bleus fait
pour leur montrer ce qui a été fait est
là allez tous les créateurs reçoivent
dans leur lieu plus de 17000 personnes
dix sept mille visiteurs ils sont
regonflés à bloc ils racontent leur
histoire ils racontent comment ils ont
créé
comment ils sont arrivés là comme si guy
guy guy y inviter le public à prendre le
thé dans son oasis de rêve ou djidji il
est des voyages
avec son décor digne de films de
bollywood ou encore ces jeunes du foyer
soleil qui n'arrêtait pas de jouer au
paintball pour colorer toutes leurs
pièces leur magic pièces comme il disait
et jusqu'à la fin du musée éphémère
ils ont continué de créer c'était
pourtant éphémère mais c'est comme la
vie on peut la perdre à tout moment et
pourtant on n'y pense pas alors on
avance et on va jusqu'au bout et même si
une fois l'oeuvre finie le musée a fermé
ses portes que tout a été détruit
il reste les souvenirs et les étoiles
dans les yeux des gens dans les yeux des
habitants dans les yeux des visiteurs
qui ont eu la chance d'être là au bon
moment
sept mois dans la peau de la famille de
la tour c'est quelque chose dans ce
quartier il n'y a pas que les tours qui
sont tombés il ya aussi les barrières
les idées toutes faites les préjugés et
tout ce qui coince notre quotidien ces
carapaces qui on ferme nos âmes d'enfant
alors c'est trop bon dosé de notre côté
on a fait nos cartons on a rendu les
clés du château vous pouvez plus
s'arrêter
on voulait cette fois investir un lieu
qui nous permettrait d'y rester plus
longtemps
il crée une plateforme expérimentale où
tout serait possible
hélas la ville de lorient nous offre un
lieu magique au péristyle parce que dans
le fond et y croit parce qu'ils nous
font confiance et ils savent que ça
marche fort
le recyclage devient notre moteur on y
recycle tout à idées détournées
même les têtes une belle ressourcerie
mental où l'on propose des ateliers
créatifs où on fait du recyclage où
chacun partage son savoir-faire et
devient un animateur d'un jour on retape
des meubles on imagine des projets fous
des rendez vous pour faire la fête et on
y vient aussi pour ne rien faire
ensemble qu'on invente les noëls
enchanteurs pendant huit ans on décore
le centre ville de lorient et avec plus
de 800 habitants ont des corps comment
décorer sa maison de famille bien on
participe à plein de festivals en
bretagne on détourne des lieux insolites
et aussi on vit notre défilé de la mode
dernier tri la raison ce défilé nous a
amenés jusqu'à berlin en 2013
on a été sélectionné en fait pour notre
talent créatif bien sûr mais surtout
pour notre talent collectif et on était
comme dans un film ou un jour j'ai juste
dit et j'ai juste proposé à quelques
bénévoles de réaliser des tenues en
déchets pré triés
c'est parti à 200 à l'heure une
vingtaine de personnes en plongée dans
ce nouveau gros délire et départ toutes
les petites mains de l'assaut je pense à
mélanie qui réalisent des robes dignes
de grands stylistes
elle n'arrête plus le jour la nuit elle
aussi elle court devant sa maladie alors
ce voyage c'était comme un gros cadeau
certains n'avaient jamais pris l'avion
il parlait même pas allemand il peut
importe on serait ensemble et ensemble
on est tellement fort je n'oublierai
jamais l'ovation non plus du public à la
fin du défilé les larmes et les rires
la fierté d'être là d'avoir eu la chance
de vivre ça une semaine a tout partagé
même les chambres une semaine de rêve
mais qu'on n'a pas rêvé qu'on a vécu
tous ensemble et qu'on a vécu pour de
vrai c'est toujours difficile de
redescendre des histoires aussi fortes
mais on sait qu'il y en aura beaucoup
d'autres
alors ça fait moins mal aujourd'hui
beaucoup de visiteurs qui passent à
idées des nous demande mais pourquoi ça
n'existe pas ailleurs
pourquoi il y en a pas dans toutes les
villes de france des lieux comme ça des
lieux de liberté des lieux de créativité
pour tous des lieux simple je me demande
aussi parce que dans le fond je crois
qu'il suffit juste dose et de se faire
confiance avoir la gnac il est surtout
d'être dans le partage alors si parmi
vous il ya des gens qui ont très envie
de monter des lieux comme ça des lieux
très fort je vous invite à passer à
idées détournées
je crois que c'est la plus belle des
cartes de visite et pour tous ceux qui
veulent tenter l'aventuré
les prochaines aventures avec nous
dépêchez-vous parce que elles sont déjà
en route et vous pouvez toujours prendre
le train et j'ai trop envie de vous dire
à demain